wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the super
foods you must
start eating enjoy
okay let's kick it off with food number
one use olive oil with dr steven gundry
the only purpose of food is to get olive
oil into your mouth
there are three long-lived societies in
the blue zones that use a liter of olive
oil per week
that's about 12 to 14 tablespoons a day
can i use it to saute
you can use it to saute believe it or
not there's a wonderful paper from the
nih
showing that olive oil does not break
down into harmful compounds
that's amazing but bring olive oil to
the table
so if you're going to have a steak
please pour it on your meat
as they do in italy they always bring a
bottle of olive oil
so you can have steak florentina and
just drench it with olive oil
the steak is there to get olive oil into
your mouth broccoli is there to get
olive oil into your mouth
a salad is there to get olive oil into
your mouth so
there are wonderful cruciferous
vegetables you can have
all the bok choy broccoli cauliflower
have cauliflower pizzas there's a great
recipe in my cookbook
for cauliflower pizza uh can i have
japanese sweet potatoes
yes please oh they're so good yeah but
the purpose of the sweet potato is to
get olive oil into your mouth yes
which works for me just fine if i can
saute or use an
air fryer yeah have you done yesterday
oh my god they're like french fries they
sure are
so yeah so those are great for you
things like yucca or
yucca make phenomenal french fries
but parboil them first and then put them
in the airfryer
also any tuber so like celerac root is
fantastic jicama
so get some guacamole believe it or not
true guacamole does not have tomatoes in
it that's an american whatever
and get yourself some jicama sticks
trader joe's has them lots of
plain old grocery stores have them use
that as your dipping chip
other thing i like people to get is
vegetables in the chicory family
the more chicory you can get in your
life radicchio the kind of italian red
lettuce
is pure inulin and your gut bugs will
love
love it for it food number two keep it
fresh and natural with oprah winfrey
you want to ideally start off with foods
that don't have food labels
right because if they're coming out of
the ground looking the way look when you
eat them
they're good for you in general so we
want to have antioxidant foods
five to seven fistfuls or servings a day
now what does that mean
tomatoes broccoli by the way you notice
they're colorful foods
red uh kidney and pinto beans these are
all great sources of protein
kidney beans blueberries artichokes and
dried prunes okay great
great now you want omega-3 fats yes now
remember eighty percent
of our brain is fat so we need to have
the right kinds of fats in our body to
make sure our brain is the most
resilient to stress and can learn the
fastest in fact you want three grams a
day
but the thing i want to point out to all
of you is that every infant formula in
america has to have omega-3 fats in it
why is that it's because the child's iq
increases
by about 10 points if they're given
omega-3 fats
and mothers when they have children that
children want that omega-3 for their
brain
they'll take it from you and that causes
depression don't you get omegas from
fishes
yeah so you get them from fish you can
get them from vegetarian sources flax
seeds if you grind them up
but you have to grind them to get the
benefit walnuts you want about a handful
of walnuts or 12 if you want to count
them
uh salmon and scallops again about a
deck of cards amount of these will get
you the omega-3 fats that you desire
and soybeans and squash are again
vegetarian sources and you can get
omega-3
sources in many of the foods we
recommend but again it's the healthy
fats so these tend to be
foods that don't have long shelf lives
so you got to eat them fresh scallops
soybeans
squash okay i didn't know squash was one
of them
okay fiber the average american gets
about 12 grams of fiber a day we need to
double that
fiber sources of course the oatmeal we
talk about all the time 100 whole grain
don't go for the head fake right it
can't be
just a word that sounds like 100 it's
got to say 100 on it
lentils have them black beans peas and
by the way raspberries had some okay
next olive oil why is olive oil so
important it's not just because of the
fat
and you want by the way about a
tablespoon a day but it's also because
there are lots of other chemicals called
phenols
in olive oil and does it matter if it's
virgin or extra virgin
it matters that it's one of those okay
you don't want processed
uh heated olive oil because when it gets
chemically processed you lose those
very precious nutrients and this is the
reason by the way why the mediterranean
diet
has been shown to increase life
expectancy because you when you mix
olive oil with the tomatoes we showed
earlier right you make pasta sauce
and if you get that into your diet a
couple times a week you're getting these
nutrients naturally
okay so antioxidants omega-3s
fiber and olive oil exactly okay
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and self-love check out my
254 series they're free
the links join are in the description
below i wished i could it's the one
thing i wish i could do but i think it's
a gift
to be able to sing and that's not what i
was given but
since i was given so many others do what
you want to do do what the [ __ ] is it
that you
really want to do because if someone
else is doing it you can do it
you have to treat yourself like you
matter because if you don't then you
don't take care of yourself
and you become vengeful food number
three eat
meat you should mostly eat real foods
like
i feel better when i eat meat and
vegetables that's why
when i'm you know i had jordan peterson
on and he had some pretty serious
autoimmune disorders and his body was
really
in trouble wow and his daughter had
similar
problems and his daughter went to
essentially a diet of just meat and
greens
and now i think she's on a carnivore
diet and she's got a
instagram page too documenting it but he
went to
meet and greens lost a ton of weight
lot was losing i think he said he's
losing what does he say like seven
pounds a month
for something like something along those
lines he lost a ton of weight
and looks great he said he's thinner
than he's been in 25 years
feels great all his autoimmune issues
were done i think a lot of what people
are dealing with
is inflammation that's caused by too
much processed carbohydrates too much
simple refined carbohydrates and sugars
and the inflammation
leads to disease so if you look at what
they call the five scourges
of health they are obesity cancer
cognitive decline heart disease and
diabetes those are all metabolic
those are all things that we get through
food and over half the people that are
in the hospital
today right now in the united states are
in there for metabolic
issues so that's crazy you're on this
carnivore diet
now okay so i want to preface that with
something i am not a dietary expert so
i'm now
speaking as an uninformed citizen yes
well this is anecdotal evidence from a
human being that has dealt with
autoimmune issues
yes your whole life yes you have done
this for how long now
i've been on a pure carnivore diet for
about two months and
a pretty a very very low carb greens
only
modified carnivore diet for about a year
so in the year and and a low carb diet
for two years
so from the time that i've known you
i've known you for what two and a half
years now sometimes
yeah yeah when i first met you you had
much more weight on your body yeah you
looked different yeah
and you were back then you were eating
like the
standard diet right like normal people
yes pasta
bread meat chicken whatever yes right
you shifted over to only meat and greens
i saw you and i'm like
you look fantastic i'm like what are you
doing you're like i changed my diet i
only eat meat and greens i was like
wow that's fascinating well i felt like
okay what you're doing is cutting out
refined sugars and all these different
things that are problematic
preservatives all the bullsh processed
foods and you're having this extreme
health benefit i was like wow that's
really excellent
you're showing great discipline then you
decided to take it to another place and
cut out the greens yeah i know what was
the motivation for cutting out the
greens well all of the motivation for
this has been my experience with my
daughter because she has an unbelievably
serious
autoimmune disease i just talked to her
what is it called well
it's arthritis but it there's there's
way more to it than that but
the arthritis was the major set of
symptoms she had 40 affected joints
and she had to have her hip replaced and
her ankle replaced when she was 15 and
16 and so
she basically hobbled around on two
broken legs for two years in extreme
agony
and that was just a tiny fraction of the
of the whole set of problems
i just talked to her this morning she's
in chicago looks like she has to have
her ankle replacement replaced
so that's next on the horizon but but
apart from that she is doing so well now
it is
absolutely beyond comprehension so she's
she's she's very trim she had a baby but
she's very trim she's down to about 118
pounds she's about five foot six
she's just glowing with health all of
her autoimmune system symptoms are gone
all of them and she was also seriously
depressed like severely depressed
way worse than you think she couldn't
stay awake for more than about six hours
without taking ritalin
and she was dying and i had a cousin my
cousin's daughter
she died when she was 30 from an
associated autoimmune condition so
there's a fair bit of this in our family
it was bloody bleak i'll tell you
and my wife always had a suspicion that
this was dietary related
you know and well we did notice that
when michaela was young if she ate
oranges
or strawberries that she'd get a rash
like there were there were
and then when she developed arthritis if
she ate oranges in particular that would
definitely cause a flare it was the only
thing we could see
the problem is is that in order to
identify a dietary component the
response has to be pretty
quick after you eat the thing like if
it's two days later how the hell are you
going to figure that out
a lot of these responses appear to be
delayed for four days
and last a month so good luck figuring
that out
anyways michaela noticed about three
years ago no more than that now five
years ago
she was at concordia university and
struggling with her
with her illness and and all the
association associated problems
she noticed that around exam time she
was starting to develop real skin
problems and my cousin's daughter who i
mentioned had really bad skin problems
and
wounds that wouldn't heal and that was
partly part of the process that
eventually killed her
and she thought oh it must be stress and
then she thought wait a second i really
changed my diet when i'm studying all i
do is eat bagels all i do is eat bread
sandwiches she thought maybe it's the
bread
so she cut out gluten first and
it had a remarkable effect like a really
remarkable effect
and then she she went on a radical
elimination diet all the way down to
nothing but chicken and broccoli
and then her symptoms started to drop
off one by one like
and and like one of the things that
happened is she started to wake up in
the morning she started to be able to
stay awake all day and when you're only
staying awake for six hours with riddle
ritalin staying awake all
day that's like having a life and so a
whole bunch of things improved
then her depression went away and i've
had depression since i was
13 probably and very severe and i've
treated it a variety of ways some of
them quite successfully
but it's been a constant battle and my
father had it and his father had it and
it's all just rife in my family two
years ago she said dad you have tried
this diet because you have a lot of the
same symptoms as me
now i didn't have arthritis but i had a
lot of the other symptoms and i thought
oh christ okay michaela i can try
anything for a month
she said try it for a month i thought
okay whatever i can hang by my
fingernails from the windowsill for a
month it's like
it's just not that big a deal and so i i
eliminated
i went on a really low carb diet okay so
this is what happened
i had gastric reflux disorder and i was
snoring quite a lot
i stopped snoring the first week i
thought what the hell
that's supposed to be associated with
weight loss because i had gained some
weight i weighed about 212 pounds and
i'm about six one and a half so that was
my maximum weight
i stopped snoring which was a great
relief to tammy that just quit and
that's a big deal right because if you
snore you have sleep apnea and then you
don't sleep
right it's like not a good thing okay
next
i started waking up in the mornings i'd
never been able to wake up in the
mornings my whole life
i always had to stumble to the shower
and then maybe i could wake up it took
me an hour and i felt terrible
and so all of a sudden i woke up and i
was like oh look at that i'm awake in
the morning and i'm clear-headed and
and things aren't gloomy and horrible
it's like well isn't that weird
then i lost seven pounds the first month
i thought
seven pounds that's a lot in a month and
i'd already gone for a whole year on a
sugar-free diet and i didn't lose any
weight and i'd been exercising
sugar-free but did you cut out bread
no no it was just no desserts no sugar
no and i thought that might do it didn't
make any difference at all
seven pounds well then
then i lost seven pounds the next month
then i lost seven pounds the next month
i lost seven pounds every month for
seven months like i'd throw away all my
clothes
i went back to the same weight that i
was when i was 26 and my psoriasis
disappeared
and i had floaters in my right eye and
they cleared up and then
the last thing that went away for me i
was still having a [ __ ] of a time with
mood regulation and that sucked because
when i changed my diet i
didn't respond to antidepressants
properly anymore they weren't working
and so although i was getting better
physically in a variety of ways like
radical ways i was really having a [ __ ]
of a time regulating my mood and i was
having sporadic really negative
reactions to food
when i ate something i shouldn't so that
took about a year and a half to clear up
and
i was still really anxious in the
morning up to three months ago like
horribly and then it would get better
all day
people said well you're under a lot of
stress and i thought yeah yeah i've been
under a lot of stress for like 10 years
it's like
it's a lot but it wasn't any more
stressful than helping my daughter deal
with her illness that's for sure
that no this is something different and
she said to me
quit eating greens and i thought oh
really jesus michaela i'm eating
cucumbers lettuce broccoli
and chicken and beef it's like i have to
cut out the goddamn greens
it's like try it for a month okay
within a week i was 25 less anxious in
the morning within two weeks 75
and i've been better every single day
i'm better now probably than i've ever
been in my life and i haven't been
taking antidepressants for a whole year
and food number four the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is eat positive pranic food with
sadhguru in the yogic culture we
classify
foods into three categories positive
chronic food
negative chronic food and zero chronic
food positive prana means
it adds a certain chronic energy to the
system when you consume
negative prana takes away energy from
the system
zero neither adds no takes away it's
eaten for taste and lethargy
so if you eat positive chronic food
energy will reverberate in a dynamic way
[Music]
particularly some of the things were
very very positive or the ash god
the ash god is very very highly positive
you i think these days you're only
hanging it in front of your house or
breaking at three corners of the road
and giving it to the buffalo but you are
not eating it
[Music]
no this is to be eaten because the
vegetable has such
high chronic energy you put it in front
of your home
so that there is nice energy but if
there is so much energy to it
isn't it good to put it into you
it's good to put it into you especially
if you consume
there are many experiments on this if
you consume a glass of escort juice
every day
the number of cancerous cells in your
body will dramatically come down
and you will see clearly the sharpness
of your intellect will enhance itself
when we were eating for survival we eat
whatever we could lay our hands on
now that we have choices we have to
choose what's best for the
body if we don't choose like this then
we will somehow live on goal
all these things are relevant only for
those people
who are constantly striving how to
better their life
how to perform little better how to
open up another dimension of life if
these concerns are there
then what kind of food or fuel you put
into this machine
is very very important now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated but never
created a plan and when you share your
plan
and have accountability you give
yourself an even higher chance of
following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
i want you to remember that nutrition is
medicine
the wisest cultures understood that if
you want to heal
if you want to live longer one of the
greatest forms of all medicine
is your diet your nutrition so i want
you to think about
food as not only fuel but food as
medicine and i want you to also think of
food as a mood enhancer
if you eat the right foods you're going
to feel happier you're going to feel
better i don't know what diet or
nutrition plan is going to be best for
you
i've relatively recently got my genome
mapped out
and that was a game changer for me
because then the genomist
said wow because of your dna because of
your genetics
you need to be on this kind of a diet
and if you don't get onto this kind of a
diet
this is what could happen and this is
what's good what could happen
so if it's possible for you i really
encourage you to go to a genome mist
and get your genome done and then
understand
what foods are going to be best for you
based on your genetic
profile this is totally a game changer
because a lot of us we read a book and
we go oh
i guess i should be on the ketogenic
diet oh i guess i
should be on this diet oh i guess i
should fast well
personally i'm not giving you
nutritional advice but i'm just saying
i don't really see how you can pick a
nutritional plan
unless you first have your genome mapped
out so that it's really tailored for you
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
below me and if you want to learn how to
bio hack
your body check the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe i'll see you there